before we get started this episode I
just want to tell you about our Black
Friday offer if you go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash friday22
you can get 12 issues of The Spectator
for just 12 pounds and a free bottle of
Johnny Walker that's spectator.co.uk
forward slash Friday 2-2
[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on November 24th I'm Cindy
Yu The Spectators assistant editor
coming up on the shade
is China more involved in the war in
Ukraine than it likes to admit oh
Matthews writes about China's secret
role in this week's cover article and
joins the show together with a security
expert Emma Ashford and has normal
politics returned after months of
turbulence the government is now talking
about housing while labor proposes laws
reform for once we're not talking about
some kind of Tory psychodrama I'll be
joined by Katie boss and James osyth
and a few years after Britain has left
the EU some are wondering whether brexit
is to blame for economic woes I'm joined
by spectator chairman Andrew Neil and
Professor Robert Holmes to discuss
whether brexit Britain was really all it
set out to be
and while we have Angie we also chat to
him and tangio Rashid about the BBC's
100th birthday has Auntie lost her touch
finally Toby Young joins the show to
tell us about his obsession with health
which he writes about in this week's
issue I'll be hearing all about his
hypochondriac routine
first up since Russia invaded Ukraine in
February China has sat on the sidelines
unwilling to help the wrestling
mediations while blaming NATO
expansionism for making Russia invade
but is its position really so simple in
this week's cover article o Matthews
writes up the incredible Revelation that
Beijing and DC have in fact been using
back channels to prevent the war from
going nuclear he joins me now together
with security expert Emma Ashford
Owen and Emma welcome to spectator TV
now own I'm fascinated by your cover
piece this week tell us about your
Revelation that the Chinese were
actually involved in the U-turn over the
Polish mix and whether or not they were
supplied to Ukraine earlier in the
spring because publicly that had been
mooted as a thing and then it never
happened and you're saying that the
Chinese had some something to do with
that well yes um I'm in a broader sense
the whole the story is about China as
sort of a giant sort of sleeping partner
the elephant in the room that no one
talks about because they've actually
kept their public diplomacy extremely
low profile but according to a source of
mine who I've known for nearly 30 years
who works very closely with the Chinese
government
there was a back Channel intervention
what diplomats called track two
through former
European leaders who retired who have
had links with China who approached the
U.S Administration and effectively
um
communicated to Washington the
displeasure of Beijing about further
escalation in the Ukrainian Invasion and
what did that mean in practice I mean
it's a very fluid time as the beginning
of March and no one quite knew what
NATO's the scale of Nature's
intervention was going to be and the
Chinese basically drew a line in the
sand rather somewhat arbitrarily over
the 30 odd mig-29s that the Polish Air
Force were going to give to the
Ukrainian Air Force and Washington
initially approved it and then a day
later you turned and said like no this
is a step too far and the one of the
major reasons for that was that Chinese
message and ever since and the
significance of it is that ever since
NATO's Military Support to Ukraine it's
the material supports being huge the
military support has always been very
limited and the question is why you know
why are we the question that the
ukrainians are asking why don't you give
us enough arms to really you know kick
Russia out and the answer is that in
part I think there's a lot of
nervousness in the west about the
consequences of a catastrophic collapse
of the Russian army and a revolutionary
situation in Russia but as I reveal in
this piece another
plank of that thinking is that Beijing
has made it very clear that they will
not help the Russian economy or military
as long as NATO does not intervene with
strategic weapons that's the parameters
of the deal that was basically or the
understanding that was made it was not
really a deal it was the understanding
that was struck in back in March and now
we see with the G20 you have a she
Narendra modri Modi and Biden basically
all effectively condemning Putin and
condemning the use of Battlefield
nuclear weapons and that's actually an
enormous shift for China who started the
Year by signing back in February a
Eternal friendship with
between China and Russia and now we have
effectively one year the foreign
minister doing intense shuttle diplomacy
between NATO between Washington and he
met shorts last week and basically not
meeting or not really dealing with the
Russians so clearly China's been on a
strategic Journey between
February and now particularly over the
use of nuclear weapons right so has that
been a red line for China and is that
why they didn't want the war to be
escalated through the supply of Polish
mix I think I think it's it's more or
less the only thing that they really
care about is to keep the nuclear
Dimension out of Ukraine and there's a
clear
strategic reason for them to do that
because they want to keep the nuclear
Dimension out of the potential conflict
with Taiwan absolutely now Emma are you
use the rhetoric publicly between the US
and China the west and China Russia and
the West has been so aggressive and
belligerent
um that you know it is interesting to
know that these back channels are kind
of negotiating almost as if there's a
proxy war in the Ukraine
honestly this is actually extremely
encouraging reporting in a certain way
because it suggests you know not not
only that you know many of us had
assumed for a long time that China was
basically doing what it was doing out of
pure self-interest that it was
um focused very much on the Potential
Threat of U.S sanctions um and this
suggests I think more strategic thinking
from the leadership in Beijing that they
are you know they're trying to keep a
lid on this trying to keep a lid on the
nuclear Dimension but also trying to
stop this escalating into a broader
Russia NATO conflict that they they seem
to see that they have a strategic
interest in that and these back Channel
Communications again they're quite
encouraging you know we see that Beijing
seems to be willing to talk to
Washington privately Washington even as
the Biden Administration is pursuing
this extremely confrontational rhetoric
and public in the National Security
strategy
um are willing to talk to China
privately and this is this is very
pragmatic real politic diplomacy um and
and I think you know this this is
something we should honestly kind of be
welcoming rather than being skeptical of
I mean this is you know be my reading of
the situation so far the Chinese are
very pragmatic very self-interested and
a lot of people in the west thought that
the Chinese were on the Russian side uh
because it wouldn't condemn Russia you
know or for always talk of national
sovereignty when the Ukrainian
sovereignty was infringed Chinese had
nothing
um but at the same time you know I think
what we're seeing is that actually the
Chinese are very self-interested but
it's not just the West I've got it wrong
is I mean you're reviewing your piece
that the Russians also thought the
Chinese would come to help much more
tell us about that right well Emma's
completely right and so are you that
actually the Chinese are of course
extremely pragmatic and there's a very
sound reason for that is that actually
Russia has a fantasy of it being itself
being a giant superpower and a major
strategic partner of beijing's but
actually in terms of in economic terms
Russia is China's 11th largest trading
partner there are term countries which
are more important than Russia
economically to Beijing and in fact
Russia's now does about 100 50 billion
dollars worth of business I mean up from
last year by about 30 billion due to
extra oil imports by China versus at
least 1.5 trillion the China business
that China does for the West so the
Chinese businesses know which side their
bread is better which is the most
important economic relationship the
problem was that China did nothing to
discourage
Russia's fantasy that they that China
was their big strategic mate and the
wording of the
unlimited Limitless friendship deal of
February the 4th of this year struck
personally between Putin and XI in
Beijing just before the Olympia the
Winter Olympics uh suggested that indeed
this was like a major strategic
partnership and to answer your question
yes I think that the for the Kremlin
they believed that a non-publicized
confidential Annex to this which the
Russians have been asking for for many
years within the partnership within the
framework of the Shanghai Corporation
organization and so on which was NATO
Style
Article 5 is Mutual Security guarantees
that had always been missing in the
relationship and then in February they
finally got it however it was qualified
by the Chinese in a very clever way so
for instance the wording I haven't
actually seen the wording because I only
have my sources word for this but the uh
it's confidential but the uh the
security pact was specifically excluded
territories annexed by Russia in Wartime
so that basically gets China off the
hook on diff on obliging China to defend
Russia when it gets kicked out of
Ukrainian territories that it's annexed
but indeed that illusion I think was a
contributing factor I mean I don't think
it was the the major Tipping Point but I
think Putin's mind was made up largely
before that but it was a big piece of
the puzzle that they felt that with the
Chinese security backing and with
Chinese assurances that they would
defend Russia if it was directly
attacked by NATO that put them in a more
secure and comfortable position to
attack Ukraine it was definitely a
contributing factor now and I mean I
don't want our audience to get too
excited and thinking that the Chinese
might come to you know in the middle of
this war and do what macron wants them
to do and end it early with some kind of
negotiated piece because I don't think
the Chinese would really go beyond that
narrow self-interest of preventing
nuclear war but can we see in those kind
of back channels that they can be
translated into wider areas of U.S China
relations not just on Russia Ukraine but
on other areas because frankly we need
these two superpowers to get along at
least not provoking War
um in order for us to all live
peacefully in the over the coming
decades
so I mean we already kind of talked
about the good news here and the good
news is that clearly in situations where
both sides have a an important National
interest or strategic interest the U.S
and China are willing to talk
um the bad news is though that I really
don't think that this is going to be
translatable out to many other big
questions
um and that's perhaps or most likely
because there are going to be situations
in which the US and China are simply not
going to be able to see eye to eye on
these problems I mean the the implicit
deal that Owen outlined is is actually a
very good deal for us and it's a pretty
good deal for China too right no
strategic weapons in exchange for no
Chinese economic or Military Support in
Ukraine that that works out for
everybody but most other issues whether
it's um territory in East Asia South
China Sea whether it's some of these
trade Wars that we've been having
there's there's not nearly as much
common ground and so I really don't see
this necessarily getting getting
translated out where I think and again
this is sort of the the interesting part
for me here is on the Russia angle um
you know we see that the Russians not
only I think misunderstood what they
could expect from Beijing but have also
through this war placed themselves in a
very poor position vis-a-vis negotiating
with with Beijing in the future so um
they've sort of cut off their strategic
options as well Emma and Owen thank you
very much for joining us spectator TV
a week after the Autumn statement it
seems like normal politics may have
returned for once instead of the Tory
Psycho Drama the government is occupied
with policies to improve housing while
negotiating with the unions and labor is
proposing some policies of its own I'm
joined by The Spectators political
editor James Forsyth and Deputy
political editor Katie Bulls
so Katie and James welcome to spectator
TV James it's been a week since the
Autumn statement and no resignations
this week has the Tory Psycho Drama kind
of been put on pause for a bit so I
think there were two immediate risks to
your Autumn statement one was that the
markets decided it was not enough they
wanted more specificity that has not
transpired you know um Sterling is doing
uh fairly well against the dollar uh and
and there's been no great spike in the
guilty years they've gone a bit but
there's no no great equals a concerned
the second question was is they gonna
was there going to be a big Tory Revolt
people saying oh my word we can't be the
party that puts up taxes we'll vote down
these measures there have been some
noises off but that has not yet turned
into a full-blown revolt and I think the
other interesting thing about it is I
think
budgets get in trouble when individual
measures get split off from the rest of
the package and kind of isolated and
then they become quite hard to defend
that hasn't happened so estimate Bay who
I think has been the most vocal in uh
opposition to the budget she's kind of
opposing the whole thing outright she's
not saying no I really dislike the fact
that the 20p income tax threshold is
being frozen she's saying that she is
unhappy with the whole package which in
some ways makes things easier because
rebellions are dangerous when they when
people start all coming on board against
one particular measure
um so I think things have
by the standards of this year and that's
admittedly a low bar things have calmed
down a bit I mean on average just being
in resignation every four four days or
something like that I've been so many
resumes that it is quite remarkable and
it's also remarkable but uh a week in
which uh the Prime Minister announces
who is going to investigate the Deputy
Prime Minister uh over bullying
allegations you know but in normal times
that would be a massive story that would
dominate for days but because of the
sheer level of political volatility and
drama this year it just doesn't seem
that dramatic and Katie is there
attention Brewing on the back benches
about the planning reforms that the
government wants to put through yes so
we saw or at least registering Act was
faced with the prospect of his first
Commons Rebellion from his own side this
week and it was an amendment to leveling
up Bill
um on planning which would ultimately
get rid of mandatory Targets in terms of
house building and there's been lots of
warnings particularly from Colville
who's a Cole for the 2019 Manifesto so
this effectively be disastrous and if
you want to have younger voters move to
the Tories
um this would be the worst thing you
could possibly do now Theresa Villas has
been leading the rebellion and so she
it's her Amendment and getting them to
support it and they reached you know
around 50 and before the government made
the decision to delay the vote and also
said oh this shows we're soon I can't
get anything through and I think you've
got to look at this probably if you take
a step back in the sense I don't think
this is about British United's
leadership now
planning rebellions have happened under
you know every leading Boris Johnson
after he won his majority of 80 he was
saying oh we're going to have you know
the biggest planning reform Revolution
you've seen for decades
um talking really tough in the end he
had to back down on that quite
substantially and he changed the
Secretary of State in that department
from Robert genre
um he was seen somebody could not get um
the Rebels on the side to Michael Gove
and therefore he speak to the rebels
they're saying well actually in a way
we're enjoying the fact that
government's a bit more stable now
because it means we can do things like
this and you know we're back to debating
legislation and and trying to get our
calls head that way of course if the
government is paralyzed and can't have
very long term on these issues on
something which is such a key concern to
lots of people particularly younger
people and that is a problem for the
government and but I think over the next
few weeks you'll see Michael trying to
listen to their concerns see if there is
a landing Zone and see if their way to
pick off some of the rebels to a point
where you can move this forward because
on the other hand you have Simon Clark
who a former leveling up secretary he's
now saying well if you're going to have
what he would call the nimby's um trying
to you know stop uh growth and Fanning
and he will have his own amendment to
try and boost it and this is event uh on
Chong wind and therefore you're seeing
different factions come together so this
was ultimately facing a headache for
Michael Gove but this isn't done yet and
James something else I said the cat
among the pigeons um over the weekend
was this story about Swiss style uh
negotiation there's arrangements with
the EU and surely I'm going to be
speaking to Andrew Neil about this and
whether or not brexit has paid off its
dividends is the government trying to
soften its brexit relationship what's
going on there no I mean the government
of being at Great pains since Sunday
Times to try and and put this story to
bed I mean which is United went out of
his way at the CBI to say no this is not
what we're doing we're not looking for a
relationship based on alignment I I
think I think there is a I think there
is a there is a question here though
which is you know this brexit deal in
2020 you know there is a natural in the
Boris Johnson deal there is a review
Clause now if you talk to some people
that you know I think I don't I think
there are people who think that you can
improve on this deal in in certain
respects like for example recognizing
professional qualifications you know uh
you know saying that you know German
Architects can come here and do that and
work their work would be valid and vice
versa I I don't think that would be
particularly controversial but I think
if you're going to get there you need
better relations with the EU than than
currently there is the idea that any
Tory government is going to sign up to a
rule taking model I think I think it's
just it's just it I think it I think it
would be a bad idea for an economy of
the UK's size uh to basically be
accepting your rules with no say on them
but I also think it would be politically
undoable for a conservative government
and Katie Irving Scotland we've also
heard about Nicholas surgeon's Ambitions
to make Scotland independent one more
development in that story so we had the
supreme court judgment this week and
it's effectively saying no Nicholas
sturgeon cannot free the Scottish
Parliament mandate a referendum on
Scottish independence about
westminster's permission and therefore
it is I think if the universe were
looking for a vet they wanted this would
be it because it means that they could
not you know laterally have a referendum
But ultimately and I think has um the
editor of The Spectator phrase and
Nelson has written it doesn't end here
um I don't think it was ever the case
the uh the case of the referendum was
going to be purely decided in the courts
and it's about public opinion so the
imminent threat of one and before the
next election has been taken off the
table but you're already seeing Nicholas
sturgeon saying well voters can make
their feelings be known at the next
general election and you can see it you
can see how there is still potential for
it to backfire if it looks as a
Westminster and the UK government is
saying never can Scotland have a say on
this
um and therefore does really soon like
find himself in a situation where his
government is under pressure to say when
public opinion hits a certain Mark the
government will review it what is the
line at the next election and I think
that's one to watch I think it was
interesting about the hope of Southern
government is is that this ruling is
going to see a breakout of infighting in
the SNP of where this was such a a wise
decision to go through the courts when
you now have this ruling and the idea is
if you can have the s p
um fighting with each other and that
means they have less time to fight with
others
Katie and James thanks very much
like having second thoughts about brexit
over the weekend there were reports that
the government is Seeking a closer
relationship with the EU a so-called
Swiss style Arrangement where one poll
claimed to show that there's now a
majority for remain in the country
engineer wrote that with the Autumn
statement last week that was when brexit
died and he joins me now together with
cambridge's Professor Robert Toombs who
warns against the return of project fear
Andrew Robert thank you so much for
joining spectator TV now Andrew you
writing your column for the Daily Mail
on Saturday that last week was the week
that brexit died can you tell us about
what you were talking about
well what I meant by that was that the
direction the government is now taking
the country in economic Direction uh
because of the war in Ukraine the
post-pandemic the the rather disastrous
trusts into regnum the direction of that
is a high tax Direction it's a big state
Direction
it uh it basically not going ahead with
a lot of the the Freeport the free zones
that Liz trust was talking about it
seems to me to be taking the country in
the direction not of anything like
Singapore on Thames which was a kind of
useless shorthand anyway but more like
Britain on the rain I mean the ironic
thing of the board is it the more
um we're in the brexit period the more
we're now becoming like a European
Social Democratic a Christian Democratic
economy and that as a result the the
promise of a different way from roaches
what the brexit is promises a different
way of doing things well so far anyway
it doesn't seem to be happening and I
think they are running out of time
because these tax Rises that have been
announced
um and the size of the state that we're
gonna that we are now heading towards
the biggest ever in modern British
history will not be easily reversed and
we could be lumbered with this big tax
big State uh culmination for quite some
time and that wasn't as far as I can
remember anyway the brexity of vision
well well Robert I think I think it's
fair to say that you're a bracelet here
was that division of brexit Britain that
you had what we're living through at the
moment well I wish I could disagree with
Andrew but I have to say I think that
everything he said is is absolutely
right uh it's true I think that you know
Brick City has wanted different sorts of
things and some certainly wanted to sort
of Singapore on terms some wanted the
opposite some wanted a more
interventionist State a leveling up
agenda sort of one nation Vision uh I I
would I was much more in favor of the
latter I mean singaporeon terms never
seemed very realistic uh and indeed
Singapore as Andrew implied isn't isn't
like many people think it is it's very
Interventional the system
so yes I thought it was an opportunity
for us to get away from what looked like
a rather failed and tired consensus
about the way the economy in the country
was run uh towards one that would be
much uh fairer much more integrated and
much more independent and although we
didn't all agree on exactly what we
wanted I mean the whole point of
democracy is that's how you you that's
how you work out what you want
uh and yes it hasn't worked out like
that I agree and partly for the reasons
that Andrew has said that the pandemic
and so on I think too because the
conservative party has been
fundamentally divided on this that the
forces against brexit are much more
powerful and much more determined than I
think most of us suspected I mean I
wrote rather optimistically that I
thought in a few years you wouldn't ever
be able to find anyone who'd who who'd
voted remain
um because it would have become so
obviously
a a sort of feta complete but as it is I
think the uncertainty about whether
brexit is really happening or not has
has just kept the division going it's
it's the uncertainty that has done that
partly and also the governments I'm
afraid pretty lamentable failure to do
almost anything of the things it
promised have meant that people are
inevitably blaming this on brexit and
I've seen recent uh you know recent um
uh polling well not just polling figures
but a sort of graph of um of of opinion
on brexit which shows that it tends to
go up and down with the perceived
success of the government's economic
policies and so at the moment it's very
difficult to see how it could be
anywhere other than down and you know
there are some very influential voices
that are determined to blame everything
that happens on brexit
um but Andrew how much of this is down
to politicians Robert there suggests
that it still remain a forces at play
but I also don't hear much of a positive
vision from brexiteer politicians
themselves
I mean I think there's no question that
uh the remainers have been re-motivated
uh by this uh the the more realistic of
them which by that I mean the ones that
are not on Twitter the more realistic of
them uh realize we're not going to join
the European Union again anytime out too
that's that's not going to happen so to
some extent the brexiteers still have
time to show to us if they can that it
was a worthwhile decision to take but
the remains I think see that it's not
worked out as the brexiteers told us and
that there is an opportunity there hence
you you see two things in the public
discourse now each time we told the
truth about brexit it was a disastrous
decision uh argument and let's be honest
about that you see that voice being held
a lot and then you hear talk so to watch
you at the moment but getting louder
that now maybe we should rejoin the
single Market or maybe we should rejoin
the Customs Union and I think the
problem actually is look in one to one
extent the brexiteers have been unlucky
because everything was derailed by the
pandemic and then derailed Again by the
war in Ukraine and so I I don't I think
that's pretty unarguable on the other
hand it is quite clear they never had
really a post-brexit plan Theresa May as
the government certainly didn't have any
idea what to do about brexit in a sense
why should she because she was a
remainder on the other hand why would a
brexit party choose a remainder to be
the Prime Minister because a lot of the
brexiteers have formed a circular firing
squad and shot each other so that was
their own uh problem Boris Johnson's aim
was simply to get it done uh whatever it
took to tell the northern ire something
that wasn't true
um to to settle for a border down the
IRC rather than between north and south
of Ireland he didn't he he had what he
called his Avent ready plan to get
brexit across the line he had no real
vision of quarter would be and and I
think also the British how can I put
this the British political Elite
particularly on the conservatives I is
just exhausted now you know it's been in
power for 12 years the pandemic's
exhausted of the war of Ukraine the cost
of living crisis is exhausting it you
don't really get the impression that
they have the energy or the vision to
get together and say right what are we
going to do to make this a success what
do we have to change how can we be
different how can we take advantage
because I mean I think the one Solace
the brexiteers contained I think it is a
pretty miserable time for the brexite
years the one thing they can take is the
European Union at the moment is going
nowhere the European Union economic
model is not something that anybody
really wants to copy at the moment
Europe is still in long-term economic
decline
Germany and the center of Europe is now
realizing that Mrs merkel's 16 years
where he disasters for Germany making
Germany dependent on Russian gas making
Germany dependent on uh exports to China
so making yourself dependent on two
totalitarian States and at the same time
uh a green policy which is resulted in
spending a trillion euros and still
using late night called The Justice in
the world to fire up your power stations
and I think when you add all that
together the the the the the center of
Europe the power that matters is now in
some trouble and therefore Europe is now
in in some trouble but can the British
come up with an alternative way the jury
is still out on that
I mean Robert before and after of 2016
we've gone through so many years of
argument National debate about brexit
but do you agree that it seems like the
braces once they had the opportunity
once this ability was given them nobody
really knew what to do whether you
yourself have just talked about two
different Visions but even that second
Vision the leveling up Vision you know
Boris Johnson articulated it but didn't
do anything about it
yes I'm afraid that's true uh what what
can I say yes I think you know the after
the after the 2019 elections there
seemed to be and indeed surely there was
a huge political opportunity to remake
the whole of British politics lots of
people said that and what happened you
know what what happened to the
opportunity well it was it was it was
partly lost because of the pandemic okay
as Andrew said but it's also fritted
Away by a lack of determination a lack
of vision and I think I think I guess
part of the problem was
uh and I'm sorry to say this but I mean
I think part of the problem was that um
there was there was too much assumption
that the EU was going to give in you
know that they would be sensible we
signed a protocol but after all the
protocol was supposed to be temporary
surely the Europeans wouldn't insist on
uh on on putting artificial barriers in
the way of trade with Northern Ireland
surely you know things would be worked
out all right if only we were nicer then
they'd be nice back to us and I think
that was a rather let's say rather naive
reading of it but you know all that
Andrew said about Europe is like I could
not put it as well as that myself as
forcefully and as as clearly as he did
and it makes me think that the argument
in Britain is not really about the EU or
Europe it's essentially about who runs
Britain now am I too cynical Andrew has
his ear much closer to the ground
infinitely more than I have but it seems
to me that if you were to take a
dispassionate view of the sort that he
took you'd have to say well look the
eu's in real trouble it's not something
that we can read seriously suggest
reattaching ourselves to so we've got to
make the best of a difficult situation
but instead we do have people saying you
know now is our chance to get back into
the single Market or the or the Customs
Union and is this really a serious
analysis of our economic and political
situation and of that of the EU or is it
just one side of what's become a very
deep and bitter division saying we're
going to win are we going to rub your
noses in it I mean I was on a platform
with a you know a very personable and
rising star in the labor party who
basically said we've got to force the
brexiteers to recognize that brexit's
been a failure and that seems to me to
be a political strategy to destroy the
Tory party and to get labor back into
Power which is a a very reasonable
ambition for a labor politician but it's
it means that the whole debate has very
little to do it seems to me with Europe
the world and you know what we might
think of as long-term strategy well can
I I play remain a devil's advocate here
then because there's an argument that
you're hearing quite a lot over the last
few weeks that yes of course Europe is
struggling especially economically but
when you look at the British economy
it's still going to be performing the
worst out of all G7 countries out of
most oecd countries I mean surely if
everyone is suffering any the EU is
suffering less than we are maybe we
should go back in you know why why is it
that the UK has been suffering more
that's how the argument goes
well I think it would be a big mistake
to base policy on an oecd forecast
because that's all there is it's just a
forecast and the oecd is in the same
oecds in the same league as the obr when
it comes to forecast it's invariably uh
wrong uh and uh I think the oecd
forecast will be rolling in the British
they all be our forecast uh we will be
wrong I think in a whole also there is
we're kind of stuck
stop thinking that in high inflations
with us for a long time and low growth
is with us for a long time my own view
is that actually inflation will plummet
by the end of next year uh for the same
reasons that would happen in the first
place and we'll be and indeed people
have not noticed that the obr forecast
actually forecasts in 2025 deflation in
Britain price is actually full in
Britain by then now you can believe that
or not but it does it seems to me to be
a mistake to base it on forecasts listen
I think there's a lot of nonsense around
at the moment the remainers are playing
the long game they know that we're not
going back in anytime soon even though
brexit hasn't worked but they think come
the turn of the decade and brexit hasn't
produced any visible dividends then that
will be the time Meanwhile we're not
going to have a Swiss style Arrangement
that story floated in the Sunday Times
complete nonsense from beginning to end
for one very good reason the European
Union hates the Swiss relationship it
involves over a hundred separate
bilateral treaties which the swings are
trying to read and go see some of whom
the EU others they've had no progress on
anything but the last thing Europe wants
is that another Swiss Arrangement nor is
going back into the single Market a
credible policy at the moment for the
simple political reason that both the
conservatives and labor want that red
wall vote and if you go back into the
single Market there is no way you will
be allowed in unless you give back free
movement of people and good luck with
the red wall if you've given back free
movement of people so what I think you
will see instead of laboring and send
them the pulse tells that it's the most
like the result is that a storm or
government will try to get closer to
Europe it won't do a Swiss deal it won't
do a single Market deal it won't do a
customs Union but it will not begin to
make our regulations very different it
will not go down a different route in
financial services it will still try to
keep us close to Europe and it will bide
its time and if in five years time a
labor government has been successful and
brexit isn't the toxic subject it is now
then you could see us beginning to move
back in bit by bit I think it's a much
longer game if the Tories get reelected
because I don't think they've got time
to do much before the election they will
need to come up with a number of ways of
regulation on
research and development on getting away
from the credential irregulatory
environment that the EU has to a more
risk-based regulatory environment if you
take a combination of our universities
um we have a distinguished Professor for
one of the best with us to today that
London Cambridge Oxford triangle there's
nowhere like it in Europe nobody has
that the Americans have the the
Europeans don't if you add in rmd our
venture capital or a new regulatory
system that encourages risk and
Innovation then I could see a difference
but that will take another five years of
Tory rule I'm not sure that's on the
cards and I wouldn't expect to get it
from a Starbucks well that's fascinating
Andrew Robert give us your take on
what's going to happen in the next few
years because Rishi CNAC is a brexit
here but even if he was full-blooded to
kind of um Jacob Reese mock stop brexit
he's as Andrew says he's only got two
years left and we may very well be
heading into a labor government so what
hope is there for a brexitude agenda at
the moment
I wish I could say there was more but I
think you know almost anything which
okay to put it bluntly creates a barrier
towards our rejoining would be welcome
signing uh trade agreements with uh with
the trans-pacific partnership or as with
as we have done with Japan and Australia
and so on you know that those would be
things that you would um have to give up
or you might have to give up if you said
you'd go back to into the Customs Union
and also deregulation I mean Andrew
mentioned um uh deregulation of research
things like artificial intelligence and
also things like Gene editing all those
things are are important and could be
seen to be valuable
um and I didn't I mean they wouldn't
surely they could be done in in two
years but I'm afraid I'm getting to the
rather despairing position of hoping
that we shall be saved by the faders of
the EU itself
for the reasons Andrew described so so
forcefully the EU is in serious trouble
and the more trouble it gets into the
less attractive it will become as a
future partner and hopefully more people
will realize that we have to make our
way with with brexit and not try to
reverse it because we'd be we'd be
moving from the frying pan Into the Fire
and you know things like inflation
um the the the energy crises that are
likely to happen in Europe they haven't
already inflation is higher in parts of
the EU than it is in Britain you know
perhaps these things will become clearer
despite the the rather dense fog of
propaganda that some people have been
putting out in recent weeks Robert and
Andrew thank you so much and Robert
we're going to let you go for now but um
Andrew do stay on the line because I
want to talk to you next about the BBC
the BBC turns 100 this year in the Arts
leader of this week's magazine Tanja
Rashid a writer and sometime BBC
freelancer says that the broadcaster
once great is now running out of steam
tanjo joins me and Andrew now
so tanjo you've tuned in to a few of
these commemorative programs that the
BBC has made to celebrate his 100th
birthday
um having reviewed them for The
Spectator in the Arts League this week
what is your overriding impression
well I as I mentioned in my piece I I
happen to share a birthday with the BBC
uh I'm not 100 years old but uh on the
18th of October I was born on the same
day as the the BBC so and that's not the
only reason I've um got a degree of
identification with the BBC I you know I
grew up like like most of us sort of
listening to and watching all of these
programs and they're really it really
sort of shaped my uh my life my views
values Etc so so always taking a strong
interest in um in the BBC and watching
and listening to these sort of
commemorative Centenary programs I I was
left with a sort of with a feeling of
um that that a sort of a great period
had passed and I'd maybe lived through
the sort of the the latter days of of a
golden age perhaps and um you know I a
lot of these programs broadcast
um as part of the Centenary are sort of
archive based
um you know for finding sort of
incredible sort of Clips with Incredible
people incredible moments from the
history of broadcasting whether from you
know the Arts or reporting Great Moments
in the history of of not just Britain
but the world and I I was I was struck
by how brilliant it was and that got me
thinking uh about whether you know the
stuff that's going out now the stuff
that I in fact have often been involved
in producing since I work as a producer
in television would they would they fit
the bill would they you know meet the
mark would they sort of uh in 100 years
time deserve the same treatment and and
the sad impression that I was left with
was probably not
um so so as I say at the end of my piece
you know I got the impression that the
BBC was this once great engine of
culture but it's been sort of gradually
losing Steam and perhaps even grounding
to a halt wow yeah um Andrew you've been
involved with the BBC for a quarter of
that century and would you agree with
tanzo
well I was born on the same year as the
BBC it was invented 100 years ago
as well you're looking great I mean I
think the BBC is one of the great
institutions of modern times it's one of
the things the rest of the world
Associates with Britain if you look at
what what um
what does the rest of the world like
about Britain or admire about Britain
the royal family uh the English language
English literature uh the BBC is there
are armed forces and the BBC these are
the kind of things that give written its
reputation
uh and to that extent it's been a huge
asset and it's done some wonderful
things over the year both in high
culture and in popular culture uh
but it's funding mechanism
was invented in the same year that
Lennon was rolling out his new economic
plan in Moscow
that born a law
another short-lived conservative prime
minister was prime minister though he
did last a little bit longer than Liz
truss and warring Warren Harding had
become president America and was just
beginning to Grapple with what became
known as The Teapot Dome scandal which
was the what again of his time I
mentioned that to show all these things
that are funding mechanisms agreed then
cannot really be the funding mechanism
for 2022 onwards and I think the risk
for the BBC the the is that because the
license fee is so comfortable it's great
to get four billion quid guaranteed
income
the the mood will be let's not change
that let's not mess with that
whereas the truth is in a world of
incredible change in technology
and with the streaming Giants
changing the economics of broadcasting
forever making it more expensive but
also much more high quality ironically
even with 4 billion pounds in the
license for you the BBC is short of
money it just can't compete when I first
started in the BBC the cost of an hour
of high quality Prime Time drama was
about three four hundred thousand pounds
today there is no change from three
million pounds for one hour Netflix is
spending 12 million pounds on each
episode of the crown The Game of Thrones
was over 12 million dollars for each
episode and if the BBC is to compete in
high quality drama it needs a better
funding mechanism it needs more money it
needs to change now whether it will is
another matter because one of the
problems Britain has always had is
Comfort let's just carry on do what
we're doing we're great aren't we why do
we need to change and I've said you go
that way you go the way of uppercloud
ship Builders uh in other words you
cease to exist in about 10 years time
you need to change
and change in a way that will give you
the money to compete in this new world
of broadcasting and what about what
about composition for the news Broad
Angie because you founded Skye you found
a GB news you've clearly always seen the
need for Insurgent broadcasters does
that come from a place of thinking that
they add something to the BBC or that
they can make the BBC redundant one day
well one of the interesting things is
when I launched Sky way back now in 1989
which offered a choice that had been
unavailable in Britain before but had
been available for a while in America I
thought the BBC would be the one to
suffer most but it wasn't I think
because the BBC is quite good at
reacting to competition and also because
of the brand name is still so so strong
uh I mean I don't think GB news is going
to cause anybody any problems
um
but and ironically in a world of a lot
of choice when you look at the EPG your
electronic program guide up when you see
the initials of BBC they actually jump
out now because oh I know that channel
trust that channel know where it's
coming from so in a way a well a a set
of initials of the strong reputation uh
are very
um important in a multi-channel world
but I think the the problem is
you because it's funded by the license
fee which means everybody whether they
watch it or not the BBC feels compelled
to do lots of popular programming
program that will be done by the market
whereas the original purpose of the
license fee was really to do some
programming that may not be done with
the market and I'd suggest it that the
best way forward for the BBC to ensure
is future for the next hundred years is
really to divide it into two to have a
BBC core as I would call it which does
all the stuff the market doesn't do high
quality drama upmarket drama uh serious
culture serious music series art
National events National sporting events
all the things that we turn to the BBC
for political program news of course
and that should be funded through what I
would call an Arts Council of the air
um and I think it would cost about a
billion pounds to do all that everything
else should go into BBC commercial and
if you stand and fall and whether the
BBC can raise subscription money or not
after all if it's such a great brand
name doing such great programs surely
people will pay for the way they pay for
Netflix I think that would ensure both a
high quality BBC outputs and a BBC that
would have the money to compete against
the streaming Giants will that happen
I'm not sure it will and probably the
license fee will be rolled over and that
will probably mean the BBC enters a
period of long-term and inevitable
decline
well tangible also talk about the
content because I learned from your
piece actually that George Orwell's 1984
was inspired by the BBC from his time
working there I mean that doesn't say
great things about what he perceived to
be the culture of censorship I mean what
we'll see you inspired by oh yes
Orwell's a great BBC figure he delivered
many BBC broadcasts especially what used
to be called talks the BBC had had a
talks Department it's not something that
exists anymore and in fact this was this
was a great genre of broadcasts many
many great writers and and um poets and
so on were involved in these these
things called talks and it's a genre
that's completely disappeared from the
air it doesn't exist anymore but um I
mean going back to all world I mean I
think he perceived that um the BBC
wasn't just
um this uh this impartial completely
neutral institution that was uh
reporting on events in the world it was
very much bound up with the state
um which is true and of course I I do
believe we have a pretty impartial and
pretty neutral BBC News
um you know and other broadcasts and and
so on but all well sort of could see the
the uh the danger
um potentially I mean obviously it's
it's a fictionalization but he he was
certainly inspired even just physically
inspired by uh broadcasting house and
and you can if you read the descriptions
of um certain parts of 1984 you would
you would recognize uh broadcasting this
um but um but yes I mean it's
interesting what Andrew uh says about
um you know his vision for uh a BBC core
in a more commercial BBC I mean I think
this is quite quite a sort of an
old-fashioned
um uh idea that I don't think would
really be sustained um in our culture
because we don't we don't exist in a
culture anymore where people are are
willing to accept that there are certain
good things
um like you know like like eating
spinach that that are not pleasurable
that they don't really want to do uh but
they just should pay to be to be fed it
regardless we don't have that sort of
hierarchical culture anymore
um in you know the culture in which the
BBC was founded where you had the
wrethian principles of
um you know to inform educate and
entertain
um I mean most people want to be
entertained do they really want to be
informed to some extent but
um you know maybe not to the extent that
the the founders of the BBC understood
and certainly this you know the idea of
Hugh world and a great um you know BBC
executive and producer had this
wonderful Maxim you know that the BBC
should should make the the uh the the
good popular and the popular good and
and this sort of improving elevating
idea of of culture I I don't think has
the public
um would have public Ascent really I
don't think we we really sort of
um want to be bettered by people there
are still public support for license fee
yes I think I think there is better
public support for the license fee but
you if you if you see what the BBC has
been doing
um you know in recent decades it's
progressively been moving to a more sort
of uh essentially
um essentially there's very little to
distinguish with BBC from from other
commercial broadcasters that they're not
making the kinds of sort of highbrow
programs to the extent that they used to
I mean this is clear from you know I
mean a lot of my impressions of the BBC
have been shaped by my experience
working there and it's you know almost
everything almost every program I work
on ceases to exist shortly after I I
leave and I don't think that's got
anything to do with me
um it's simply that a lot of these very
good quality programs that I've worked
for there's just not the appetite for
them I mean I I used my first job in BBC
was the BBC Arena a great uh
long-standing extremely highbrow Arts
documentary series
um that made programs about you know
great cultural figures and I mean I
think they make maybe one film a year
and begrudgingly the BBC uh makes maybe
one film a year just to say that the
program still exists but it doesn't
really
um and I I so so I think the culture has
moved on really uh I don't think the
values that shaped the foundation of the
BBC at least culturally um are still
present um to the extent that would
justify
um the existence of the BBC I I don't
agree with that I think the the
conditions are still there we we have
the South Bank and we have the West End
the South Bank is supported by state
subsidy and the West End is a commercial
operation but the West End would be
poorer if it wasn't for the South Bank
because the South Bank has helped to
create the skills that give us the West
End and a number of shows when they're
successful they're transferred to the
West End and in my how I would see it is
the BBC core which will be available to
everybody would be in some ways to be
the South Bank and BBC subscription or
BBC commercial would be the West End and
you know as a consequence of having the
BBC and also Channel 4 with all the uh
number of smaller production companies
that it has helped encourage over the
years this country is now a production
superpower uh by October of this year
there will be more Hollywood
Blockbusters made in Britain than in
Hollywood
by September of this year there will be
more Studio space in greater London than
there is in Greater Los Angeles around
12 billion pounds of money will be spent
on TV and motion picture production in
this country this year 12 billion more
than anywhere in the world outside of
America and that creates highly paid
jobs skills it's not just in London
Belfast dines out on Game of Thrones and
the Titanic now and Manchester has
become a big production Hub classical's
become a decent sized production hub
this is what helps make as a soft power
of importance soft power something of a
superpower and of course we have the
huge advantage of the English language
and the name the BBC still matters all
over the world when I work for the BBC
and I was traveling abroad and I said
the BBC it opened doors people had heard
of the BBC they knew about the BBC and I
don't think you want to give that away
but I don't think it can continue with
the current you say the support for the
license fee there's no support for
increasing the license fee indeed the
license fee is effectively been frozen
under this government in real terms for
the past decade and that means the BBC
is running out of money we need to find
more ways and it has to be commercial of
getting money into the BBC while
protecting the core
non-market programming that the BBC does
there would be more Arenas in my ways of
doing things there would be more Arts
coverage there would be more serious
music on the BBC if you did it this way
but there would also be more money to
make more high quality drama that you
can sell to the rest of the world uh
but I fear that there is almost no
appetite on the left or the right or
going down in this world
Andrew and Tanger will have to leave it
there thank you very much
and finally Toby Young writes in this
week's magazine about the pharmaceutical
concoction he takes to stay healthy
but is it more faith than science Toby
joins me now
so Toby let's start by going through
your pharmaceutical routine tell me
about it yes so um I've I've for several
years now uh possibly decades I've been
going through the same routine uh to
ward off colds and other infections so I
take
um I take a multivitamin tablet I take
some vitamin E some vitamin D
um I take
um I wash it all down with
um a thousand milligrams of Vitamin C
orange juice or literally blackcurrant
flavored kind of fizzy tablet okay wow
dissolved in water yeah and uh and then
I've also I've added recently I've added
um psyllium husks
um uh what's that stuff called for your
bones calcium no
um uh begins with tea anyway I'll be
taking that as well and um and a ginger
shot so it takes me about 10 minutes to
get through this routine every day
um and my wife and children ridicule me
for they think I've been kind of you
know duped by a snake oil salesman and
it's for General Health isn't it
generally for General Health yeah yeah
it's not not for anything in particular
it's just a ward off yeah um getting any
kind of virus and sometimes you take it
twice sometimes I forget that I've taken
it on a particular day so my wife
complains about the extraordinary
expense I mean just just 100 capsules of
this kind of quite high-end
um vitamin E costs almost 20 pounds and
my wife is constantly chastising me for
spending all this money on what is
essentially snake oil
um and and I haven't had the heart to
tell her that sometimes I actually take
everything twice because I forget that
I've taken it and I'm going to have to
invest one of these days in one of those
kind of
um pill dispensers with kind of each day
of the week kind of demarcated in little
compartments well Toby you know that
those pill boxes they bring to mind you
know pen tensioners or people you know
much older than yourself if I may say so
what is where does this come from do you
think because reading between the lines
of your column as well it doesn't really
sound like you believe that it quite
works either no I I think well I suppose
one of the um one of the kind of
oddities of this routine is that I do
think of myself actually as almost
superhumanly healthy so the last time I
had a day off work when I felt compelled
to stay in bed because I felt so ill was
in the summer of 1987 and since then I
don't think I've ever taken a day off
work from sickness
um and I work most weekends too even
when I've had covered twice but that
didn't stop me working
um and uh so why why why am I so
obsessed with my health given that I'm
unbelievably healthy and I think
actually that is probably a Hallmark of
a hypochondriac I mean by definition
hypochondriacs are never ill right you
know because if they were they wouldn't
be happy a contracts they'd be you know
realistically assessing their health and
to be a kind of world-class
hypochondriac I think you have to have
not been ill for about 35 years so I put
myself in that Elite group kind of hyper
super neurotic kind of people about
their health but so you don't know
yourself then from from what I'm hearing
you don't know quite I mean it always
sounds like a article of faith when you
say like ward off you know well I
suppose it's a bit like Pascal's wager
you know even though you know these
things are probably useless they might
just be having an impact and I sort of
superstitiously fear that if I broke
with my routine one day then I'd
suddenly come down with a really bad by
writing about it am I coming to talk to
me maybe a little bit yeah yeah maybe a
little bit I I did say in the piece I
think at the End by the time you read
this I may have been rushed to hospital
with a heart attack well not yet it's
not yet not yet and hopefully we won't
give you anything here from from the
studio and I also just wanted to pick
you up on on this incredible insight
into your upbringing because I wasn't
sure if you were joking or not about
picking up chicken bones from the
pavement and pass these from the bins I
wasn't maybe exaggerating a little bit
right but um yeah I think one of the
reasons I am
um uh unusually healthy
um is because I have a very robust
immune system and the reason for that I
think is because I had unbelievably
negligent parents
um so from the age of five I was really
about to run wild on the Streets of
London I mean I would literally at the
weekend leave the house at about 8 A.M
clutching a skateboard or something and
wouldn't return till about seven or
eight at night and my parents you know
they weren't remotely concerned that I'd
been run over or kidnapped or anything
like that they just assumed I'd be okay
and I was okay but they weren't kind of
big eaters themselves they were both
very frugal not really interested in
food they were kind of you know
non-conformist socialist kind of hair
shirt type so didn't really have much
interest in life's luxuries such as food
um and uh and so I was really I had to
fend for myself they didn't give me
lunch money or you know a pack of
sandwiches to take school I embarked on
the two mile walk you know aged five to
the local comprehensive um or whatever
um and uh so I did have to kind of fend
for myself in terms of you know I mean
you know I would scrounge food uh from
friends but sometimes if I saw kind of
you know a half eaten Burger in a bin I
would take the burger out of the bin and
finish it off if I saw something on the
floor easily a half eaten sweet or a
kind of you know a fox's Glacier mint
half in its rapper half out I pick it up
and eat it you know
um didn't have much alternative I wanted
to stay alive and it turned out that
this kind of approach to Parenting was
actually you know a real gift that they
gave me because you know from the age of
about 18 I think I've only I mean the
number of days I felt so ill I was
immobilized I could count on one hand do
you feel like you're letting your
children down by not starving them I do
sometimes think but I'm really you know
as a parent I'm really hopeless and a
bit of a deadbeat because I actually do
feed them three times a day and often
take them to school
young thank you so much for joining us
TV
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to The Spectators
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
that's everything for this week thanks
again for watching and do join us again
next time
[Music]